oh hey critic Merry Christmas Eve
don't marry about it by adjusting the
absolute worst holiday special of all
time
Santa zombie eats Jesus worse it so bad
I even slept tonight it's kept me awake
throughout the entire season if I'm not
careful I might start hallucinating
hey critic are you talking to you carry
my quill
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
Merry Christmas Eve to you more ELISA
would be before I found out this unholy
abomination existed that's right I ain't
found it I found it's the absolute worst
Christmas special of all time hands down
no comparison Yuletide crap it's cold
the Christmas tree it's unlikely you've
ever heard of it but it's getting more
and more of a following as you guessed
it the worst holiday special ever made
it's acting atrocious
it's animation beyond sheep its story
what brain operated by a dead hamster on
a broken spinning wheel would be fucking
stupid enough to bring like this shit it
might be the only Christmas special
where literally everything about it was
done completely 100% wrong and I mean
everything there are no words to
describe how bad it is it just has to be
witnessed and that is why you are here
isn't it you are interested in the
unknown the mysterious that the
unexplainable that is why you are here
and now for the first time we are
bringing to you the full story of what
happened that fateful day we are giving
to you all the evidence based only on
the secret testimonials of the miserable
souls who survived this terrifying
ordeal the incidents the places my
friend we cannot keep this a secret and
longer let us punish the guilty
let us reward the innocent my friend
it opens with a cliched narrator reading
a cliched book that looks more like a
dictionary of Tetris pieces than legible
literature our story takes place in an
orphanage with some children and a pine
tree the orphan children lived under the
control of the evil rules of a lady
named mrs. mobility I'm sorry that's a
rarely happens in this special the
children never had toys new clothes or
anything but they had a friend the pine
tree they named mrs. whoop-whoop
yes Hopewell because the kids believe
that the tree was magical the kids were
obviously exposed to too much car
exhaust to imagine such a non
imaginative idea she had a pretty dress
with bows and mace and a new pair of
pants and a sweater to put on whichever
child she was going to show off to the
mayor this way every time the mayor came
by he always thought that mrs. micawber
was taking good care of her children a
thorough inspection as you can see
accompanied by the fact that direct
deposits and business checks if not
there replaced with speed bags of money
hey who needs a paper trail when you
have millionaire deduct currency mrs.
mcdougal would immediately take off the
child's clothes and put them away in a
closet for the mayor's next visit poor
children well yours not making the
situation better by uncomfortably
holding on their naked bodies like that
thank you
so mrs. Manville de that's all the money
she has on poker games with her friends
and the kids continue to suffer for it
she doesn't even let them feed the
street dog named licorice and she tries
to have the pound take him away
what is up with this kid the other
children are at least clapping and
cheering but he's just rockin his head
like a psychopath play some heavy mellow
music over that later on we see a family
moves into town and is looking for work
so they go to the mayor which doesn't
really seem like his jurisdiction but
again he keeps his bank account in
moneybags and he tells him that the
husband can work at the lumber mill but
has to live in the boarding house
without his family however he offers the
family a chance to live at Chateau d'If
uccle where mrs. ma ville de will take
the mother named Judy in as an assistant
come from the mares I know I know I
better go now take good care of yourself
and the children Judy I will be back
before Christmas Wow David Duchovny on
quaaludes could show more emotion than
that goodbye children be good I'm gonna
check with the doctor and see if I'm
clinically still alive can we go now so
mrs. ma bilder explains that Judy's kids
have to be treated the exact same way as
the other kids they're going to stay
with the other children and under the
same rules and regulations I'm sorry
have children follow me yeah that was
that children follow me I apologize
sometimes my other personality interests
me no I don't shut up whore this is
going to be your bedroom I don't want to
hear anybody crying around here and most
of all no elephants you understand
because if you think that you're not
going to be punished because you have
your mother there you're gonna be mighty
disappoint I'll get you my frozen
awkwardly blinking pretties and you'll
have PETA two frames of animation - so
Jimmy's kids trying to see if they can
fit in with the other children
[Music]
was that supposed to be charming they
were satanically hypnotizing them what
the creepiest smiles seemed to win them
over and they start to know each other
better what the hell did you say yeah I
don't know if this kid is the directors
the producers or even the casting agents
but there is no way she got through any
kind of audition process she's not
technically killing the art of human
speech as we know it but she is the see
they will grow horrifying wheel our joke
speaking of which the kids show Doody
they're only friends the tree named mrs.
Hopewell
and their dog licorice and to the
mumbling girls credit none of these
other kids are going to win anything
resembling human respect with these
performances either I just learned how
to speak 3 days ago and according to the
Craigslist posting that's all you need
to be in this movie I've got an idea
we'll decorate her with her dead
brethren that way she'll remember that
no matter how pretty she is she'll
always be thought of as a tool much like
you children are in this movie so the
mayor sees the kids and Judy getting
along and thinks that they deserve even
more money this year I've collected more
money for the children's Christmas I've
got enough money here to get the
children new clothes and still some left
did you just have a Vietnam flashback
for a second I've got enough money here
to get the children new clothes
and still some left for their Christmas
presents here you go mrs. marvel de
here's the two bags my god he didn't
even give the amount he just said two
bags I don't even think he measures the
money in terms of numbers I think he
literally measures it in bag size mr.
mayor this cheque says it's for two
money bags
that's right two whole money bags mr.
mayor I'm gonna need an exact amount in
order to accept I use money bags okay
we'll take the money bags very good now
if you'll excuse me my ride is waiting
for me I'm glad those poor little things
aren't going to have to spend another
winter in patches and rags by the way
where's Judy Oh mrs. Kendal good there I
just gave mrs. marvel that's awfully
quick adeney hear a footstep let's just
beam herself into the room by the way
where's Judy oh this is end oh good that
you're here so the mayor wants her to
pick out fancy new clothes for the
children as Christmas gifts but the kids
don't know what Christmas is
so Judy explains Christmas is a pretty
and happy time of the year a time when
people get together friends with friends
children with their parents and
grandparents ex-navy errands pay orphans
a Santa Clauses everybody's grandpa and
how can his sleigh fly
then that's a reindeer to put and each
one has a special name okay what's this
kid drinkin she's slurring more than
inebriated Klansmen I wish my little
teddy bear and his ever arms so she
tells them that on Christmas they can
all make a simple wish no not that one
but it would explain a lot so we get a
scene of all the kids wishing for happy
things to occur but strangely enough
while this scene is going on they keep
cutting back and forth to mrs. Mulder's
poker game and it's edited so awkwardly
that we're usually only seeing the poker
game for just a couple of seconds I
guess you've never seen a Christmas tree
before
what did you want let's roll
grandpa well can I be the first one to
make a Christmas wish shake hard before
you do wait I think I don't think I'm
done yes my little teddy bear okay
why show these two things at the same
time if we're not going to show them for
more than a couple seconds till we
intercut other sloppily edited scenes
while we're at it oh maybe if there's
some money left over I can convince mrs.
marvel de to buy some red velvet that
way I can make some Christmas stockings
to hang on the fireplace don't you know
about Christmas stockings that you hang
on the fireplace for Santa Claus to film
you don't which one of you knows about
Christmas I do Christmas Christmas well
let me tell you about it so it turns out
mrs. Manville dapat all the money and
lost it
meaning she can't get any new clothes I
want to tell you something and you
better listen I don't want the children
playing outside anymore you better make
sure that's because you don't want the
mayor to see them without new clothes
how can you dare to all right now you
know and now that you know you better
make sure you don't tell him a thing are
you and your children out the cold now
you go get those children back inside
before my brain gets taken over by
another personality so Judy what's the
kids know the bad news you know the new
clothes we promised you well I'm afraid
you're not going to be getting them I
know I know but there's nothing I can do
about it it's not fair please children
don't make it more difficult for me I
mean Jesus oh you kids never do and
think about yourselves don't you kids
ever think about me thinking about you
thinking about yourselves
but mrs. Mobility decides that judy is
getting too much respect from the kids
so she tries to figure out a way to get
rid of her she's changing everything
around here I gotta get rid of her but
how
well maybe you can start by keeping out
of the fucking bed it's like one o'clock
you lazy bitch get moving
I make that good girl into a bad one
yeah I'll make her into a thief just
like I did with the girl that worked
with me before we never saw that okay is
this like a real person or are we to
assume this is yet another personality
that she has in her head
this one was making appeal for mine look
like a simple rump so she calls her
henchman yeah see you has a henchman
what with the accents and stuffs and ask
him to frame Judi for stealing something
of his what one of the girls here is her
and tells the other kids they all decide
that something has to be done okay
zort or your impression of a small human
child isn't fooling anybody
speaking of which there's a great irony
that all of these children are obviously
voiced by horrible child actors but one
girl is clearly voiced by the
eighteen-year-old you mean you don't
think our star is gonna make it on time
what if one of us goes to him but where
are we and where is this house okay pick
one either horrible adult actors
horrible child actors or aliens trying
to pose as children to take over the
universe so the children decide that
Judy's kids should go and get help from
who EMA ask Santa Claus of course yeah
why not
look here in my book it shows that we're
not far from this house what the Kip
take the gingerbread cookie do they live
on even Mario would be looking at this
saying whoa that's a hook up a kingdom I
don't know where the North Pole is do
you I don't I don't well he barked
obviously that translates into knowing
where the North Pole is quite a
knowledgeable little scamp isn't he say
I wonder what else he knows about hey
licorice do you know if we're alone in
the universe
wow do you know why smart people keep
watching the middle
Wow do you know who really killed JFK my
god the answers are right there I have
to go to the police about this the world
does know dance the world must know I'll
be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
what another commercial well this one's
really quick I just want to tell you
that at the awesome store calm we are
extending our sale on our DVDs and also
our charity Drive pictures so that is
going to be going until the first of
next year so you can still get the good
prices on that also our metal prints are
in and they're being shipped out even as
we speak if there's any more left you
can take a look see if you can order
some more and that's about it back to
the show
o also you will die if you don't know
this
so Jimmy's kids go with licorice to find
the North Pole she's down there kid
you're staring at nothing right now
please look down please look down please
look down there ya go but they come
across some troubles on their search
like Balu from The Jungle Book he says
they don't even make it a polar bear
even Santa Claus conquers the Martians
got that one right you're hanging on for
dear life show some fuckin emotion you
little twat even in death I don't care
[Music]
we're in hindsight I am a pretty dumb
oh Jesus kid well somebody just try
somebody god I'll juggle porcupines with
my buttcheeks if I could just get one
production assistant or a cast member
who or the director or somebody just to
say maybe fucking maybe we should do
that take again Jesus hates Jesus can we
just get somebody with some goddamn
emotion spastic hyenas aren't as loud as
you yeah you're blowing out the volume
levels I don't think the microphone
hasn't insane bitch setting on it yeah
except maybe in her case Frank you still
have that electric chainsaw of yours so
missus Matilda calls her henchman to cut
down the tree sorry mrs. Hopewell it
established such a strong presence with
her I'm surprised I forgot as the kids
go out and try to stop them nobody cuts
mrs. Hopewell until we talk to the mayor
show them the song whatever you say
ma'am
[Applause]
what is the meaning of this wasn't there
snow here just a moment ago turn that
thing off yura ping mommy mommy
but where is Lily where is she she's
gone mommy oh god what do you mean I
come from rain I randomly materialized
here just in time
tell me son what happened to Lily yeah
cuz that's my reaction if I just found
out my little kid died so while the
mayor is there he finds out all the
terrible things then this is Matilda has
been doing I love how he doesn't care
that the children's well-being has been
put in horrible danger but instead is
more concerned if the inspector season
and calls him out on voters don't like
their politicians connected to dead
children uh they are still alive right
you're a tree I mean mrs. Hopewell is
going to be all right okay it's the
mayor slowly transforming into an Adam
Sandler voice because Sandler already
ruined one holiday and I don't think
this movie needs any help ruining this
one that's what you think jelly
but mrs. Matilda grabs the chainsaw and
is about to finish the job
[Applause]
the moral of the story is don't fuck
with mrs. Hopewell so it was Santa who
fried the flesh of a weak people woman
Mary I think those lights are supposed
to actually be on the tree and not a
little to the left of the tree but I
guess it's the thought that counts
and clearly none of that went into this
at all and the disturbing Santa khoka
degrees what's this shit on my shoulder
oh I guess it does that okay yeah creepy
boy Santa has no time for individually
visiting houses anymore he just sort of
air bombs gifts now in the hopes that
whoever picks it up in the morning will
like it or some crap so everything seems
to end happily look even mrs. Marvel
does somehow got out without a scratch
on her how the flying fuck do you do
that and mrs. MA bilder well mrs. marvel
de she's going to be all right from what
I've heard she went back to work in the
orphanage as Judy's assistant true that
lightning fucked with her head and she
constantly pisses her pants and calls
herself the chicken God but aside from
that she's gonna be all right
well don't worry about mrs. Mathilda
she's good now
she learned that you always win when you
are good Merry Christmas everybody know
and I suppose that your half-assed
little message at the end right good job
special it was it's only 45 minutes it
felt like eternity but you know you did
good I just love it I do everything do I
even need to say what's wrong with it
not really it's pretty obvious horrible
acting horrible writing horrible
directing and horrible animation but
here's the thing a lot of people are
saying this is the animated equivalent
of the road
one of those films that's so hypnotizing
ly bad that it's actually good and in
some respects they're actually kind of
right this can be very entertaining to
laugh at and make fun of everything is
so awkward and strange that you can't
help but burst out into hilarity but the
problem is it's a Christmas movie
Christmas really think about that this
is the season where even the worst
holiday specials at least try to give
something either entertaining or
heartfelt because they feel they owe it
to such a beautiful time of year and
what does this film end up giving us you
always win when you are good yeah this
is the holiday where charities all over
the world go up and people give more
than ever to those who have so little
and expect nothing in return they do it
because they know it's right and this is
the time to celebrate what's good in the
world and what does this film end up
giving us you always win when you are
good this is the time of year that
brought a war to a halt because the
message of goodwill toward men was so
strong because it was a symbol to stop
hatred stop killing stop everything
spreading anything that didn't equal
love and respect for everyone in the
world this is a holiday that is that
powerful so just to reiterate you
Christmas special that clearly
understands the holiday you represent
what then is the meaning of Christmas
you always win when you are good because
that's what Christmas is that's what
Christmas is you got especially you
fucking got it no no you dipped and
that's why this is the word special I'll
tell you why because Christmas is not
about this not about that dumb asshole
message just trying to throw in at the
last minute you know what it's not even
really about giving or sharing or love
or anything about that that's a part of
it but there's something even more
important you all know what it is I'll
tell you what Christmases Christmas is
effort it's putting effort into that
kindness is playing effort into that
sharings play effort into that loving
cuz anyone can just give something
anyone can just buy something whether it
costs a million bucks if you're rich or
nothing of you're poor but by god it's
the effort you put into it if you got
something someone really wanted then
that's effort or if you made something
that something didn't even know they
wanted that's effort that's loving that
it's putting the effort into that stuff
and that's something that is clearly not
in this special they just slapped it
together didn't give a shit and you
can't do that on Christmas man you have
to try you have to try to make this
stuff good because that is what we're
trying to do it's about putting effort
in something that's even bigger than
yourself because when somebody comes up
to me and wishes me a holiday from a
religion maybe I don't celebrate
somebody said the Happy Hanukkah to me I
wish Merry Christmas back you know what
we'd be fine with it
you wonder why because we're both
sharing something that we believe is
bigger than ourselves that is putting
effort into them that is celebrating
something that's wonderful and loving
and unbelievable is putting that effort
into Christmas into sharing something so
great and fantastic let's show you
something follow me mr. cameraman follow
me
you know it is all about effort because
that is what we're trying to do here
we're trying to all come together so
that we can celebrate it and put that
effort into everything that is good with
the world like these people right here
look at how much extra these people put
in all the time unbelievable come here
come here you guys these are people that
work behind the scenes and from the
scenes also they do
such a good job guys you've been doing
so great you got the that got the
glasses audience watching right now
is there anything you would like to say
to them this Christmas Eve god bless us
every hood Merry Christmas mr. Potter
oh you got movie quotes odd that really
but as we approach the New Year just
know that we always want to get better
don't get drunk see that's ever whether
it be just a movie quote that means a
lot to them or you know something very
sincere but effort I love you guys you
guys are awesome but doesn't stop there
because we keep going out here showing
more of the ever more of a it's about
this guy Christmas is about this guy
right here that's right the camera man
my brother Rob he's been working so hard
no no no stand up stand up come on even
working so hard you got everybody
watching it right now anything you all
wish people this Christmas Merry
Christmas
Oh can't you do better than that come on
and the Happy New Year come on bigger
than that
[Music]
Oh forgot so you can't think of anything
better to say on Christmas Eve okay fine
it's you know it's a little hard to get
into the Christmas spirit with the way
it's been over commercializing stuff but
really when you think deep about it it's
Christmas is not just a bunch of things
that you buy it's about an attitude a
spirit something you carry with you in
your heart when two thousand years ago a
man was born into a stable not adorned
with gifts and presents and stuffing and
the entries but born into into poverty
and and you see that every day when a
child does something nice for his
grandma or when you know we give things
to homeless people you know it's
something that that that lasts that
endures and goes on and on from the
mountains may fall in the Elster
it's about believing in something bigger
than yourself like they said it when the
effort into it because you don't have to
believe in Christianity or Catholicism
or any of that stuff you don't have to
be any religion you just have to believe
in humanity and that's what's so great
about it's believing in the best of
humanity the effort puts into that
business it's about these two this is my
mom and dad they put so much effort into
raising me because they are so awesome
that way this guy joined the Navy so he
could help support and raise us and my
mom she was going to be an opera singer
but she had two kids and said you know
what I'm gonna spend my life dedicated
to that and that is so unbelievable and
that is Christmas that's such goodness
there's such goodness in these people so
then you got so many people watching
right now is there anything you want to
say to the bad guy of the glasses
audience on Christmas Eve here merry
Christmas to all of you and most
importantly remember we have lots of
merchandise in the channel awesome
century store 15 pretend that's look I
am he is that's the kind of guy that my
daddy is you can see where I got my
terrible sense of humor but nonetheless
he has spent it that come on
but nonetheless he has worked so hard to
raise us and he has just been so
positive so upbeat and I love my dad and
mom I got a question for you it's a
question I really wanted to say for you
because you're so loving and you're so
heartfelt and everything there's a lot
of people out there who don't associate
Christmas with the best stuff maybe they
don't have many friends or much family
and maybe they're spending it alone or
maybe they associated with a bad time
there's so many bad things that happen
out there and Christmas is such a good
time I know you feel it you feel like I
feel it what can you say to people out
there who are not having such a good
Christmas you know this is the time of
year to reach out to someone else who's
lonely or is having a hard time and do
something nice for them because when you
do that you'll feel less lonely inside
of yourself as well it's a perfect time
of year
to do something for somebody else and
think of others that's really nice mom
thanks so much this movie sucks balls
but I love you Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas
[Music]
thanks so much guys merry Christmas to
you who the hell was that
you're fired